[Aplausos]
buenas tardes a todos qué tal cómo
estamos
primero muchas gracias por venir y sobre
todo a aquellos que hoy han cambiado su
siesta por su asistencia
antes de empezar me gustaría haceros una
propuesta si os dijeron levantar las
manos quién de vosotros la alimentaría
venga abajo
vale por ahí veo muchas manos por ahí
algunas de acuerdo muchas gracias mirad
cada uno de nosotros hemos afrontado
esta propuesta tan simple pero de forma
diferente
unos han levantado las dos manos otra es
la derecha otros la izquierda unas con
más energía otras con menos algunos han
mirado a los demás para saber si
levantar la onu
pero todo eso nos da a entender lo
diferente que somos y diferentes formas
o actitudes que tenemos para afrontar
nos a las diversas situaciones y ahora
bien quiero que traspasemos esta
experiencia que acabamos de vivir al
ámbito de los estereotipos relacionados
con el aprendizaje de los idiomas el
mundo de los estereotipos es tan grande
que a veces nos convencemos de algo que
en realidad no somos por comunidad en
muchas ocasiones tendemos a hacer pensar
o decir aquello que parece que en la
sociedad está integrado de forma general
sin tener por qué ser así
no somos iguales y por tanto deberíamos
de comportarnos de diferentes maneras
ante los mismos retos como habéis podido
notar por mi apellido no soy de toledo
tampoco soy de españa y en la realidad
tampoco me llamo angela puesto que sólo
el equivalente a mi nombre pero las
circunstancias andas de tal manera que
mi vida durante los últimos cuatro años
está vinculada con este país con su
lengua y su cultura y la frase que bola
eres ya me suena más familiar que
cualquier otra cosa en mi propio idioma
cuando termines un de bachillerato en mi
país me fui con 17 años a polonia a
estudiar periodismo y relaciones
públicas aquellos tres años fueron el
punto de partida para el cambio de mi
mente había que empezar a comunicarme en
otro idioma acostumbrarme poco a poco a
otras costumbres a la estancia con mi
familia y a los escasos reencuentros que
íbamos a tener desde aquel momento
pero en la vida nunca sabes dónde vas a
terminar y después de obtener mi
diplomatura otra vez me tocaba dejar
todo mi nuevo entorno cambiar mi lugar
de residencia y volver a empezar todo el
cero
y cuando digo de 0 así fue porque porque
cuando eliges son los estudios que a
priori se centran en desarrollar las
aptitudes lingüísticas en saber hablar y
escribir correctamente llegas a un sitio
donde de repente te das cuenta de que
eres como un niño intentando decir o
preguntar algo expresando tus deseos sus
sentimientos tus miedos
quieres dar tu propia opinión y no
puedes hacerlo bien porque te falta
vocabulario o te lías con los tiempos
verbales y al final decides quedarte
muda percibes que no te entienden o no
les entiendes tú las primeras
expresiones donde metes la pata o las
que tienes literalmente y te enfadas y
debido que una palabra puede cambiar el
sentido de una frase entera tienes que
andar con pies de plomo
como podemos observar muchas veces lo
importante no es lo que dices sino cómo
lo dices aunque intentemos ayudar a la
gente que está aprendiendo a otros
idiomas muchas veces nos cansamos de
adivinar las palabras y viene rápido de
forma muy cuidadosa para no ofender a
nadie
terminamos la conversación lo sé por mi
propia experiencia cuando no hablas bien
la gente no te escucha atentamente y de
toma en serio
y eso es lo que más duele pese a que
procuremos ser empáticos no todos
estamos dispuestos a prestar atención
mucho tiempo nuestra mente siempre
tiende a llegar a lo más cómoda a lo más
fácil donde no hace falta esforzarse
para entender que le vamos a hacer y
todo eso con una carrera de periodismo
eso me generaba una depresión pero como
todo en la vida siempre hay que buscar
una solución creo que las ganas de
mantener una conversación desahogarme de
expresar todo lo que tenía guardado me
ayudaron a aprender el castellano más
rápido no en vano la necesidad de
comunicarse es una de las principales
necesidades que tiene el ser humano y
más todavía en el siglo 21
a menudo se oyen las frases como
vosotros tenéis facilidades para los
idiomas pero nadie nadie pregunta
cuántas horas realmente se dedica a ello
diariamente
está convencida que la constancia y las
horas invertidas son los factores que
influyen en el resultado y al final lo
que tiene peso es la necesidad
y la motivación
mi necesidad era sentirme bien a la hora
de comunicarme acorde con la edad que
tenía y con los estudios que había
realizado pero lo principal era que el
concepto llegar a la gente igual como yo
lo tenía en mente y por fin terminar con
estas mal interpretaciones que alguna
que otra vez me hicieron sentir incómoda
acabar con este teléfono roto entre mi
cabeza y mi boca
a lo largo de estos años hablando con
mis compañeros sobre el aprendizaje de
los idiomas me di cuenta que muchas
veces solemos traspasar la
responsabilidad sobre el bajo nivel al
instituto o al colegio o lo justificamos
comparando con el nivel general que
tienen los alumnos de nuestra edad o nos
referimos a este famoso estereotipo de
que los españoles no son muy buenos con
los idiomas pero hay una cosa muy
importante que a mí personalmente me
ayuda siempre es que si al menos una
persona lo puedo hacer yo también soy
capaz
entonces no sería mejor preguntar a
aquellos compañeros que si lo han
logrado y seguir el mismo plan
muchas veces decimos que tenemos la
dificultad para los idiomas pero los
humanos dependemos de lo mucho que
practiquemos y los mejores del mundo lo
son porque dedican casi todo su tiempo
libre a hacer la misma cosa entonces
cuando pensamos que tenemos esta
dificultad recordad que es una excusa
interna la excusa que está desde luego
muy bien arraigada en la mente de la
sociedad
vivimos en un mundo digitalizado donde
el mercado actual tiene una faceta muy
popular que es la simplificación de las
cosas como las geográficas o las
aplicaciones móviles el mundo de youtube
que está lleno de los vídeos que nos
puede facilitar la vida en unos minutos
así que no me voy a quedar atrás y os
quiero presentar mis 4 tips que espero
os sirvan de ayuda para cambiar el chip
romper dicho estereotipo y empezar
vuestra aventura en el mundo de los de
los idiomas con más ilusión y con más
motivación pero desde otro punto de
enfoque
estos trucos se basan en el simple hecho
de que podamos mejorar nuestros puntos
débiles
a través del desarrollo de las
fortalezas personales y estas fortalezas
personales se derivan de nuestra cultura
nuestras costumbres el entorno y de
forma de ser en general así que
empezamos el tip número uno
hay que tener mala leche
y dar la vuelta a la tortilla
os aseguro que aunque vayamos
aprendiendo palabras en otro idioma lo
que realmente se usa en español en lo
que es la herramienta más poderosa para
describir la situación las las emociones
las emociones
o dar una opinión son las expresiones y
cuando no sabemos sus equivalentes nos
podemos encontrar con dos consecuencias
la primera cuando lo traducimos
literalmente y nos sale el cierre por la
culata
o cuando nos rendimos y describimos con
otras palabras lo que convierte nuestro
comentario en pura simpleza deformada
sin colores y sin tonalidades por tanto
el poder de manejar y emplear las
expresiones con la misma frecuencia que
en el idioma nativo nos ayuda a
sentirnos más naturales ser como somos
en la vida real sin tener que ponernos
nerviosos
es una experiencia muchas veces nos
cuesta hablar o aprender otro idioma
porque no nos sentimos tan sueltos y tan
espontáneos nuestras frases nos parecen
nos pueden parecer hasta ficticias y
secas y cuando vemos que lo que decimos
no refleja nuestra verdadera
personalidad
nos sentimos raros se nos bajan los
ánimos y posteriormente la motivación de
seguir así que a practicar vista del tip
número uno veamos el siguiente el tip
número 2
qué calor hace hoy y lo harto que estoy
de esta lluvia
suena esta que se
estos pocos años me han sido suficientes
para darme cuenta que el ser humano
nunca estará satisfecho con nada
y como decimos estaría bueno si nos
pagan por quejarnos tanto pero no
sabemos dónde se vistas y vamos a
realizar lo mejor en realidad las quejas
es el mejor método para aprender
antónimos y conceptos contrastados
solamente en comentar el tiempo se puede
ganar un buen número de palabras
teniendo en cuenta que es uno de los
temas más populares para empezar una
conversación
de lo que engordado durante las
vacaciones y en lo que era el baza
durante el periodo de los exámenes de
como las las caras pasan lentamente y
cómo vuelan el tiempo durante puentes y
fiestas de lo aburrido que estoy en mi
casa y de la pereza que me da de moverlo
del sofá
de los impuntuales que somos para cuando
empieza a algún evento y super super
super puntuales cuando llega la hora de
comer o del descanso
las ganas que tengo para encontrar mi
media naranja y de lo bien que estaba de
suerte
así que por lo visto no hay mal que por
bien no venga' y que veamos este tipo y
practicarlo mucho
vamos con el tipo número 3 hablada alto
que no se os oye
todos habéis pensado esto esto no es
sobre nosotros a nosotros se nos oye
desde lejos y es verdad entonces si está
provocado por el temperamento o por
otras razones
lo que tengo aprendido es que cualquier
discusión o cualquier debate domina el
que tienen más voz o el que grita más
pero hombre cuando empieza cuando se
trata de hablar en otro idioma
se nos olvida adquirir este regalo
cultural y no es ningún secreto que
bajar la voz es el método perfecto para
camuflar los errores
como nadie nos oye nadie nos lo va a
ocurrir
no hay que tener miedo de cometer
errores de parecer reciben sus parecer
algo malo por confundir palabras
parecidas sinceramente un segundo de
vergüenza no viene mal a nadie de hecho
se aprenden mejor y no se olvida
así que a practicar y por último el tip
número 4
hablar castellano significa vocalizar
aquí no hay duda que es una de las cosas
más importantes para sonar bien en
español y no es lo mismo decir pero que
perro
pero tenido que todos tenemos poca
paciencia queremos aprender las frases
rápido sin prestar mucha atención a la
pronunciación de las mismas como
consecuencia puede pasar que algo que
esté 'a priori' dramáticamente bien
dicho no se entienda o adquiera un
significado totalmente distinto hay que
recordar que una lengua es un conjunto
de sonidos reconocibles por sus nativos
y por esa razón existen unas reglas
fonológicas y fonéticas sin las que no
se puede alcanzar la fluidez y sonar
correctamente por eso lo primero que hay
que hacer es determinar los sonidos que
no estén en vuestro idioma natal y luego
señalar aquellas letras que escriben se
escriban igual pero se pronuncian de
forma diferente una vez estén fijados
estos dos puntos hay que practicar por
separado cada uno de los sonidos
y solamente después de haberlo hecho hay
que pasar a las sílabas a las palabras
que las conllevan y por último por
último a las frases durante este proceso
es muy conveniente grabar vuestra propia
voz para comprobar si de verdad se nota
el cambio
la articulación de los sonidos es una
técnica muy útil para luchar contra el
fuerte acento que todos tenemos al
principio esto este método nos ayuda a
comprender los sonidos individualmente
ya que de otra forma nos va a resultar
más difícil captarlo al oído
y practicarlo y veréis cómo avanza es
más y al final lograréis la
pronunciación de los nativos una vez
vistos estos cuatro dips para terminar
me gustaría deciros que aunque existan
los estereotipos nosotros somos los
dueños de nuestras decisiones
no hace falta sobre valorarnos ni
tampoco infravalorar nuestras
capacidades y si de verdad queremos
centrarnos en algo centrémonos en las
ventajas en aquellas cosas que nos hacen
únicos y utilicemos la riqueza de
nuestra propia lengua de nuestra cultura
y de forma de pensar para hablar en
nuestros idiomas con más naturalidad y
con más soltura es decir crear nuestro
propio estilo tener nuestra propia
actitud
y dejar de mirar alrededor
y recordar que somos diferentes muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]